a new clinic at umc is now providing
ongoing care for people with long-term
medical complications from covet 19.
it's the first of its kind right here in
our state denise valdez is here in city
with more on its mission in today's
health watch denise well christian
university medical center's cobit
recovery clinic opened just last week
and now it's helping patients enroll in
clinical trials for new therapies and
also connecting them with specialists to
turn to treat those long-term symptoms
what are some of those symptoms from the
virus well they include heart and lung
conditions extreme fatigue for some
people brain fog hair loss ringing in
the ears it's a wide range of issues the
list is varied and often doctors have a
hard time connecting it to the aftermath
of the virus so the mission of this new
clinic is listening to their concerns
validating them and making sure your
symptoms are not dangerous and guiding
you through the treatment process
make sure that you know dangerous things
don't remain hidden for too long so that
they're addressed in a timely fashion
and then plug you into research so we're
doing a little bit of research for
partnering with turner university to do
a study on blood biomarkers for
inflammation in patients with neurologic
damage that's one of the ones we're
working on
but we're looking actively for other
research studies that are ongoing that
we can
give access to patients so that they can
participate as well
many of these so-called long-haulers
just want validations that their
symptoms are real so they can deal with
these lingering effects of the virus now
a couple of requirements to visit this
covid recovery clinic you do need a
positive covid test and it needs to be
at least three months after infection
you need to be patient to recover from
it dr medina garcia admits it's really
tough to know just how many long-haulers
do live in our area so they're not
really sure how many patients to expect
but depending on your insurance you may
need a referral but i'm told you will
not be turned away if you aren't covered